as we are we don't have to look for the
heat it has already found us for the
month of may
not much in the way of winds today light
winds out there blue skies to get
started on our wednesday check in valley
temperatures 70s mostly but a few
neighborhoods have found some 60s seven
hills mountains edge summerlin
centennial hills even some cooler 50s
out at red rock and really just not much
wind that we've got going on this
morning we're in the low 60s for indian
springs perhaps mesquite's up around 70
and mid 70s for laughlin we're looking
at highs though in the upper 90s today
that's where we've been the last few
days 89 is normal sunrise at 5 32 in
sunset at 7 43 all records for mayor in
the triple digits and we've got some
triple digits in the eight day forecast
it would be very uh might be close to
records not looking to set records but
we'll get the help of uh getting some
hotter temps tomorrow with wind coming
in from this system now pushing into the
pacific northwest with rain and even
snow showers showers and thunderstorms
across the midwest today places like
minneapolis chicago st louis even down
into louisiana and texas looking for
thunderstorms today and the northwest
this is a strong system it's going to be
a big wind producer for us today light
winds but once it starts making its way
inland that's where the winds are going
to get started again remember we were
talking about fire weather watches they
have been elevated to warnings now fire
weather warnings for all of southern
nevada tomorrow morning 11 a.m until
friday night at 8 p.m and these fire
weather warnings go all the way through
new mexico into texas poor new mexico it
is just they are in a bad way there 300
thousand acres now have burned from the
uh fire it's the hermit's peak and calf
canyon fires they are now closing the
national forest said that's the carson
and santa fe national forests until the
end of the year unless they change their
minds but it's just too dry there the
governor governor grisham is saying she
expects they could lose more than a
thousand homes to this biggest wildfire
in new mexico's state history so
it is they may not even get a handle on
that fire until july so that is just not
good news for new mexico
97 for the high today as i said and then
we'll we'll slide right into some hotter
triple digits with the help of those
gustier southwest winds tomorrow could
be up over 30 miles an hour
the winds may relax a little bit on
friday but temperatures drop behind that
cold front and look how the temps drop
maybe 80s to near 90 for friday saturday
and then we're looking at heating up to
triple digits on tuesday wednesday